[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
viola und du wirst ein sohn
verabschiedet seine mutter danke für
deine liebe und hingabe
mögen engel ich zur ruhe betten
frei zum schuss sie ist
das persönliche und geradezu private
ende seiner ersten rede an die nation
als könig guten abend zum heute journal
das war der erste tag in einer
sorgfältig geplanten choreographie die
sich über insgesamt zehn tage erstrecken
wird eine aufführung auf großer
weltbühne die der britischen monarchie
auch dazu dient sich ihrer selbst zu
vergewissern
rituale als zeichen der kontinuität sie
war immer da sagen viele trauernde
dritten über ihre verstorbene königin
nun gibt es sie nicht mehr aber so die
botschaft aus dem buckingham palast die
zweite ist zwar gegangen aber die krone
ist weiterhin da trainer gerrit
berichtet
sein volk erwartet ihn tausende briten
wollen ihren neuen könig sein
als der dritte heute einen tag nach dem
tod seiner mutter nach london kommt um
juden sie ihn
gemeinsam mit camilla geht er an den
vielen blumen und kondolenzschreiben
vorbei um dann das erste mal als könig
den da gingen kallas zu betreten
der könig konnte sich sein leben lang
auf diesen moment vorbereitet aber trotz
dieser so langen zeit mit der
unterstützung seiner mutter wird ihm
wohl erst jetzt bewusst werden wie groß
diese veränderung wirklich saniert
zeremonielle salutschüsse im ganzen land
insgesamt 96 einen für jedes lebensjahr
von elizabeth der zweite
im parlament sollte man ihr mit einer
schweigeminute respekt
überall erweisen sie ihr die letzte ehre
wie hier vor dem buckingham palast
ich bin am boden zerstört irgendwie hat
man gedacht das würde nie passieren sie
verhalten 70 jahre königin
es ist unglaublich traurig wir sind
hergekommen um uns zu verabschieden und
um damit klar zu kriegen
das land vereint in trauer wie kaum eine
andere hat elisabeth den menschen
zusammengebracht das moderne
großbritannien wird sich ohne sie neu
erfinden müssen
der größte stärke der queen weil ihre
unparteilichkeit sie hat sich nirgendwo
reinziehen lassen sie waren niemals eine
person die gespalten hat sie hat zu
keinem thema öffentlich stellung bezogen
die lücke die seine mutter im land
hinterlässt wird für den sohn schwer zu
füllen sein am abend wendet sich der
könig mit einer kurzen rede an sein volk
genau wie die königin es mit
unerschütterlicher hingabe tat so weiß
auch ich dass ich mich feierlich dazu
verpflichtet habe während der
verbleibenden zeit die mir gott gewährt
die verfassungsgrenze im herzen unserer
nation aufrechtzuerhalten
und trotz des immensen verlustes den er
betrat betonte auch das bewusstsein für
seine neue rolle
mein leben wird sich natürlich ändern
durch diese verantwortung wird es mir
nicht mehr möglich sein so viel zeit und
energie für
wohltätigkeitsorganisationen oder für
themen einzusetzen die mir am herzen
liegen ich werde diese arbeit in
vertrauensvolle hände abgeben
das wird er tun müssen es wird von ihm
verlangt
am abend trifft die neue
premierministerin lässt was das erste
mal den neuen könig charles den dritten
russ britannien in einer neuen zeit
darüber wann wir sprechen mit dem
historiker christopher clark professor
an der universität cambridge und auch
hier in deutschland bestens bekannt
unter anderem durch sein buch die
schlafwandler über den beginn des ersten
weltkriegs google mit der klage
in dieser welt wurde 1926 in der
zwischenkriegszeit geboren und waren so
von einer königin die von kindheit an in
einer erschütterten welt lebt aber sie
selbst wirkt immer vollkommen
unerschütterlich es ist das womit diese
monarchen der nation immer halt gab
absolut also sie die die königin hat mit
einer unglaublichen stetigkeit regiert
überall um sie herum gab es menschen die
wie eben menschen so sind sich
verfehlungen zu leisten meinte es gab es
trennungen das gab skandale und was das
heißt ich das normale alt das was
menschen was auf mich auch die menschen
in zukunft aber sieben immer stets also
ganz ganz fest in ihrer rolle und
spielte sie noch mit einer so
unglaublichen toll es ist interessant
also wenn man sich wenn man darf auch
nicht vergessen dass in großbritannien
keine geschriebene verfassung hat das
ist eine konstitutionelle monarchie ohne
konstitution und in dieser situation war
sie sozusagen die verkörperung diese
ansicht nicht existenten konstitutionen
diese rolle hat sie mit einer mit einem
exquisiten gefühl für die grenzen der
rolle gespielt sie hat sich nie
persönlich geäußert zu politischen
themen sie hat könnte man sagen gänzlich
im öffentlichen leben auf einig
verzichtet also sie waren da um sich
selbst zu realisieren oder zu erfüllen
sondern um das amt vor zu spielen dieses
land ist ja auch schon in der im
britischen staatswesen ein anderes als
jetzt an ein normales repräsentatives
staatsoberhaupt die wir einen
bundespräsidenten haben das hat ja auch
noch seine spezielle jahr magie und die
veg dass man die nation verkörpert
absolut an diese magie hatte sie auch
personen in das ist das
schwer fassbar ist natürlich aber das
haben fast alle erwähnt die mit ihren
begehrten bezieht die ihr begegnet sind
von ihrem persönlichen charisma
gesprochen von der freude so um sie
herum zu sein ich habe sich selbst in
cambridge mal vor vielen jahren sie trug
ein aprikosen farbenes kleid alle um
sich alle um sie herum freuten sich
wahnsinnig bei ihr zu sein sie strahlte
wie eine kleine sonne und das
davon haben davon berichtet also es gab
schon was besonderes an dieser
persönlichkeit also die wie die
persönlichkeit zu dieser rolle passt und
war schon einmal man sehen ob ihn das
auch gelingt sie hat natürlich auch
einfach sehr lange regiert ist ja
wirklich wieso ein einband in ein
anderes zeitalter und wenn man jetzt mal
rückblick nimmt wie werden historiker
wie werden sie als historiker diese ära
dieses zweite elisabeth amische
zeitalter am definieren ja das sind
interessante frage ich meine wenn man
sie mit den anderen mit den zwei anderen
großen königinnen
der ersten ist es überhaupt sehr aufwand
wie wichtig diese die königinnen gewesen
sind in der geschichte dieses landes
wenn man das diesen vergleich wort sieht
also mit elisabeth und dann mit viktoria
zwei sehr lange herrschaftszeiten beide
sehr lange auf dem thron das waren
beides zeiten wo dieses in diesem land
eine ungeheure machtentfaltung
stattfand eine macht ausdehnung die zeit
von den es wird der zweite war eine ganz
andere das war eine zeit des
zusammenschrumpfen des machtverlusts ein
weltreich ging auseinander
großbritannien musste nachdem zuerst
krise natürlich so jetzt krise meine
zurechtfinden in einer viel kleineren
rolle so eine eine macht unter vielen
anderen und da hat sie in dieser zeit
die eigentlich gar keine zeit der
kontinuität börse ein zeit der umbrüche
und der des wandels war da hat sie
während dieser zeit sozusagen doch eine
gewisse kontinuität
verkörpert einem münchen und im herzen
des universums besser verklagt danke
sehr vertieft gesprächen
und wir bleiben auch noch mal bei diesem
thema empire man man muss sich das noch
mal vor augen führen das britische
empire war die grösste kolonialmacht der
menschheitsgeschichte ein weltreich dass
zum zeitpunkt der geburt von königin
elisabeth 1926 immerhin noch ein viertel
der weltbevölkerung und auch fast ein
viertel der welt oberfläche umfasste
rund 35 millionen quadratkilometer nur
mal zum vergleich die alten römer oder
alexander der große hatten jeweils nur
fünf millionen quadratkilometern in
dieser britischen kolonialgeschichte und
ihren verwerfungen sozialen konflikte
und ressentiments die bis heute anhalten
und das mittlerweile
zusammengeschmolzene vereinigte
königreich auch weiter belasten wie es
etwa in nord irland weitergeht das kann
ein nur mit sorge erfüllen aber auch auf
der britischen insel gibt das
fliehkräfte vor allem in schottland und
dort ist unsere korrespondentin diana
zimmermann in ennetbürgen
diana dass die queen in ihrem
schottischen landsitz starb das wird sie
selbst vielleicht der hat es den
perfekten ort gefunden haben
das wird sie bestimmt getan haben
perfekt bis zum schluss vor allen dingen
deswegen weil es ihr liebster sind zwar
sie liebte dieses schottischer einsame
gemäuer es war aber auch so dass bei
modeln nicht nur der ferien sind ihrer
kindheit war bis zum tod ist hat sie
dort ferien gemacht zwar eben auch in
ihren augen der schönste teil
großbritanniens und ein sehr wichtiger
teil großbritanniens wir wissen dass sie
2014 als die schotten über ihre
unabhängigkeit von großbritannien
abstimmten sehr nervös war dass die
ausnahmsweise ihre unparteiische rolle
verlassen hat und gesagt hat die
schotten mögen bitte sehr gut darüber
nachdenken was das für ihre zukunft
bedeutet und als die schotten sich dann
dafür entschieden haben im königreich zu
bleiben so berichtet david cameron der
damalige premier habe sie gespürt wie
ein kätzchen als er es ihr verkündet hat
das wiederum hat die queen nicht gut
gefunden dann gibt's ja beobachte die
sagen jetzt wo die queen und diese queen
mit ihrer großen schottland liebe totes
hält die schotten möglicherweise nichts
mehr ab ihre unabhängigkeit und doch
sehr stark voran zu tragen
also die queen hat sicherlich auch in
schottland ihre einigende wirkungen
ausgelebt allerdings glaube ich nicht
dass das jetzt hier zu einem großen
momentum für die
unabhängigkeitsbewegungen werden wird
man darf nicht vergessen der brh exit
den die schotten gerne als
scheidungsgrund von england angeben weil
sie ihn nicht wollten aber die engländer
dafür gestimmt haben und sie nun mit im
boot sitzen der ist einerseits wirklich
ein spannendes element andererseits ist
er so schmerzlich die trennung
großbritanniens von der eu
offensichtlich so schwierig dass das
natürlich auch hier abschreckend wirkt
und das andere ist die queen hat noch
kurz vor ihrem tod boris johnson aus dem
amt entlassen und damit hat sie mit
sicherheit der unabhängigkeitsbewegung
keinen gefallen getan denn boris johnson
war eine absolute hassfigur in
schottland dass er weg ist ist erstmal
eine schwächung der unabhängigkeit und
das ist für die queen der ist so wichtig
war dass das königreich zu ihren
lebzeiten noch zusammen bleibt
sicherlich eine gute nachricht gewesen
dankeschön diana für die einschätzung
aufstieg und untergang von imperien
prägen jahr in vieler hinsicht das
schicksal unseres kontinents der
überfall russlands auf die ukraine wird
auch als kolonialkrieg bezeichnet der
versuch ein untergegangenes imperium neu
zu errichten das in russland die ukraine
als kleinbussen oder kleine brüder
bezeichnet werden bringt diese koloniale
sicht auch sprachlich zum ausdruck die
so definierten zeigen aber ja überhaupt
keine bereitschaft sich zu unterwerfen
im gegenteil den ukrainischen truppen
ist in den letzten tagen enormes
gelungen sie stoßen vor teils in
verblüffenden tempo und gewinn land
zurück und dort zeigt sich dann wie es
aussieht wenn soldaten tatsächlich als
freier begrüßt werden kann man sache
jahren berichtet
gut gemacht jungs ihr seid prachtkerl
nach einem halben jahr seid ihr endlich
da
ukrainische soldaten werden von den
einwohnern den befreiten stadt ballack
lia sehnsüchtig begrüßt bilder die über
soziale medien verbreitet werden
ukrainische soldaten hissen die fahne
über der knapp 30.000 einwohner
fassenden stadt ein wichtiger sieg der
ukrainischen gegenoffensive sagt
präsident zellen
im laufe der verteidigungs operationen
haben unsere helden dutzende ortschaften
befreit insgesamt wurden seit dem ersten
september mehr als 1000 quadratkilometer
unseres territoriums zurückerobert ich
danke dafür alle
seit tagen dringen ukrainische truppen
im osten des landes vor unter dem
beifall der bevölkerung
nach der einnahme des wichtigen
russischen vorpostens baller
klimabeitrag if stehen sie nun offenbar
vor kopien zu ein wichtiger knotenpunkt
für die versorgung im osten
wenn sie das kontrollieren kontrollieren
sie viele eisenbahnschienen die irgendwo
anders in den osten gehen was es für die
russische armee dann fast unmöglich
machen wird nachschub an die truppen an
verschiedenen stellen im osten zu
bringen die gegenoffensive zermürbt bild
der zurückgelassene russischer panzer in
der region ragt
aus dem don was kommen diese bilder
angeblich mord an der soldaten einer
freiwilligen einheit sie sind seit
sieben monaten im krieg ohne ablösung
und wollen hinschmeißen
der von russland eingesetzte
verwaltungschef der region hp spricht
von einem bedeutenden sieg der ukraine
in der region und kündigt an die städte
easy um und kopien zu evakuieren
russland reagiert und verstärkt seine
truppen ein wendepunkt im krieg deswegen
einmal glaube ich nicht das ist ein
wendepunkt im krieg ist es ist eine l
sind entscheidende tage in diesem krieg
aber keine wende punkte sind man wenn
man realistisch ist muss man ganz
einfach sehen die ukraine hat jetzt ein
bis zwei prozent des territoriums dass
die russen kontrollieren zurückerobert
das ist nicht viel aber sie haben
strategisch wichtige positionen erobert
ein kleiner etappensieg für die ukraine
und ihre bürger
naja us-verteidigungsminister osten
sprach immerhin davon dass der krieg ein
schlüsselmoment erreicht habe katrin
eigendorf ist unsere reporterin in haag
hat dann spürst du da das da auf grund
solcher erfolge ja das ist der neue
hoffnung gibt
ja das spüren wir hier vor allem in haag
im osten der ukraine wir sind ja hier in
der zweitgrößten stadt der ukraine und
für die menschen hier ist weniger
bedeutend wie viel gewinne jetzt die
ukrainische armee erzielt hat als dass
das hoffnung gibt dass sich wirklich
etwas ändern kann an dieser verfahrenen
lage die die menschen hier seit sechs
monaten erleben für die politiker vor
allem für präsident sie lenski wenn man
mit denen gespräche führt ich habe mit
seinem berater kurz nach dieser guten
nachricht gesprochen ist es vor allem
ein wichtiges signal richtung westen zu
zeigen die ukraine sind in der lage
wirklich geländegewinne zu
erobern und in diesem krieg eine wende
herbeizuführen in möglicherweise zu
gewinnen wenn sie die entsprechende
unterstützung des westens erhalten
allerdings muss man sagen man sieht dass
hinter mir hier wir sind in frankreich
der zweitgrößten stadt der ukraine es
ist hier komplette dunkelheit die stadt
wird im moment massiv von russische
armee angegriffen und die menschen sind
hier wirklich in großer angst
du warst auch in befreiten gebieten zum
teil oder auch dort herrscht große angst
ja wir hatten heute gelegenheit in eines
der befreiten dörfer hier in der nähe
von cardiff zu fahren und dort sind
natürlich die menschen auch erleichtert
die dörfer sind dort es vor zwei tagen
befreit wurden aber was wir da erlebt
haben war auch sehr traurig die dörfer
sind fast alle komplett zerstört da
steht kaum noch ein haus was wirklich
bewohnbar ist die ganzen gasleitungen
sind kaputt die ganze gegend ist auch
vermied so dass die bewohner dort nicht
einfach so zurückkehren können das ist
natürlich eine furchtbare lage das muss
man auch berücksichtigen dass sicherlich
dieser krieg und das wissen die menschen
so schnell nicht zu ende geht
danke für deine eindruck und deiner
arbeit dort für uns
und jetzt macht erstmal heinz weiter mit
den nachrichten die haushaltswoche im
bundestag ist beendet die erste lesung
des etats für das kommende jahr ist
heute abgeschlossen worden mit einem
politischen schlagabtausch zwischen den
regierungsparteien und der opposition
jetzt wird im haushaltsausschuss weiter
darüber beraten
der haushalt sieht ausgaben von gut 4
145 milliarden euro vor deutlich weniger
als in den vergangenen jahren als die
etats stärker von wirtschaftshilfen in
der korona pandemie geprägt waren
der synodale weg der reform dialog
deutscher katholiken hat seine vierte
vollversammlungen frankfurt am main
heute fortgesetzt am abend wurden reform
texte etwa zur stellung der frauen in
der kirche und zu homosexualität
beschlossen gestern war ein papier zur
liberalisierung der katholischen
sexuallehre gescheitert es hat er bei
den bischöfen keine zwei drittel
mehrheit erhalten
un-generalsekretär guterres hat die
internationale gemeinschaft zur
finanzielle hilfe für pakistan
aufgerufen das südostasiatische land
kämpfe mit den folgen der
klimakatastrophe sagte görisch bei einem
besuch in der hauptstadt islamabad
seit mitte juni ist pakistan von
ungewöhnlich starken monsunregen
betroffen ein drittel des landes steht
offiziellen angaben zufolge bereits
unter wasser bislang sind fast 1400
menschen in folge der überschwemmungen
gestorben
in ansbach gibt es nach einem
messerangriff mit mehreren verletzten
laut polizei bisher keine hinweise auf
ein islamistisches oder terroristisches
motiv der mutmaßliche täter ein 30
jähriger abgelehnte asylbewerber soll
gestern abend alleine gehandelt haben er
hatte unter anderem einen 17 jährigen
mit zwei messern angegriffen
der angreifer war bei dem vorfall in der
nähe des bahnhofs von der polizei
erschossen worden
die cdu politikerin dagmar schipanski
ist gestorben im alter von 79 jahren die
promovierte physikerin beriet als
vorsitzende des wissenschaftsrates bund
und länder zur hochschulpolitik zudem
war sie landesministerin und
landtagspräsidentin in thüringen
1999 kandidierte sie gegen johannes rau
um das bundespräsidentenamt
es gibt ein neues
zdf-politbarometer dass wir dann in
aller ausführlichkeit am ende unserer
sendung präsentieren aber ein ergebnis
jetzt schon mal vorweg die grünen und
ihr wirtschaftsminister haben ziemlich
federn gelassen die union hingegen kann
in der sonntagsfrage zulegen und wäre
derzeit stärkste kraft liegt allerdings
weiterhin deutlich unter 30 prozent
das kann friedrich merz nicht genügen
und das ist genügend auf seiner partei
nicht die hofft in der opposition nun zu
alter größe zu finden ihr parteitag
heute und morgen in hannover soll
richtungsweiser aufstellen das ist aber
kein selbstläufer beim thema frauenquote
etwa waren die delegierten gespalten
ines trams bericht
nach drei jahren ein cdu parteitag
wieder in präsenz er zeigt noch immer
sind frauen in der minderheit eine
frauenquote jahrelang diskutiert soll
das nun ändern doch konservative wie
franziska dezember die junge union und
der wirtschaftsflügel lehnen sie ab wir
müssen einen anderen stern andocken
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf und
ich möchte mir auch nicht die die wahl
vorschreiben lassen wenig zu wählen habe
ich möchte gewählt werden weil ich
überzeuge ich möchte nicht gewählt
werden weil ich eine frau bin und ich
möchte auch andere leute andere frauen
wählen weil ich sie gut finde und nicht
weil sie frauen sind sie ist verwundert
dass gerade friedrich merz der
konservative den sie als parteichef
wollte die quote nun durchziehen will
viele seiner anhänger verletzt doch für
mehr wählerinnen und ein weicheres image
nimmt er das in kauf merz selber spricht
in seiner rede die quote nicht an
stattdessen attacke gegen die
energiepolitik der androhung wir sind
die viertgrößte industrienationen der
welt die sich nicht leisten kann ein
traineeprogramm für
bundeswirtschaftsminister aufzusetzen
sondern wir brauchen
menschen in den ämtern die was verstehen
von der aufgabe die sie da wahrnehmen
und ich fordere von dieser stelle den
bundeskanzler auf stoppen sie dieses rot
grün gelben narrenschiff einen eigenen
antrag zur energiesicherheit bringt die
partei statt der das umlage soll einen
preis deckel für gas und strom geben die
drei atommeiler sollen weiterlaufen wir
haben jeden tag stresstest familien
handwerker bäckereien mittelständische
unternehmen die können seit monaten auf
ihrer stromrechnung sehen was los ist
die haben seit monaten stress wenn sie
daran denken was in diesem winter was in
den nächsten wochen einen kosten auf sie
zu kommt am abend der showdown zur
frauenquote schrittweise soll es
hochgehen auf 50 prozent frauen in den
parteivorständen es gibt wichtigeres das
weiß auch franziska dezember doch es ist
eine richtungsentscheidung wie
konservativ will die partei sein wie
angepasst
gleichstellungs und von
identitätspolitik und sie helfen kein
bisschen bei der vereinbarkeit von
familie und politischen engagement
wollen wir ernsthaft mit dem tempo
weitermachen wollen wir noch 80 jahre
brauchen bis so viele männer wie frauen
für uns in den parlamenten sitzen keine
fremdworte der welt stellt sicher dass
meine kinder mittags aus der kita
abgeholt werden auf dem parteitag will
es steht spitz auf knopf die
entscheidung könnte gegen die quote und
damit gegen märz ausfallen es geht auch
um seine autorität erkämpft dann mache
ich ihnen das angebot das sie in fünf
jahren wieder darüber sprechen und wenn
alle die prophezeiungen eingetreten sind
die wir hier von den gegnern heute
gehört haben dann fällt sie wieder unter
den tisch dann ist das thema erledigt
aber den kleinen schritt den gehen wir
doch bitte heute gemeinsam der
parteichef setzt sich durch die cdu sie
stimmt für die frauenquote fast 30 jahre
innerparteilicher kultur kampf vorbei
vorerst zumindest franziska dezember
akzeptiert das ergebnis doch sie hatte
sich ein anderes erhofft
mit blick auf den ukrainer krieg sagte
der nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg
heute der preis den wir zahlen wird in
geld gemessen der preis den die ukraine
zahlen mit den leben gemessen um den
ökonomischen preis den die europäer
zahlen möglichst abzudämpfen hat die
europäische kommission eine strategie
vorgelegt und darüber wurde heute in
brüssel verhandelt heinz und zwar auf
einem sondertreffen der energieminister
sie waren sich einig dass man mit blick
auf die hohen energiepreise keine zeit
mehr verlieren dürfen diskutiert werden
konzepte wie das umleiten von über
gewinnen von strom erzeugen zur
entlastung für verbraucher und firmen
auch ein preis deckel für russisches gas
ist im gespräch die eu kommission soll
nun die vorschläge konkret aus arbeiten
am rande des treffens in brüssel hat
sich wirtschaftsminister harbeck auch
zum gasmarkt in deutschland geäußert
konkret zu möglicher staatlicher
unterstützung für den gasversorger vng
freund bittmann wie ist da der stand der
dinge er habe rasch hilfe zugesagt vng
hat hohe verluste angesammelt weil der
importeur kein günstiges gas mehr aus
russland bezieht seit wochen ist das
leipziger unternehmen gezwungen gas zu
horrenden preisen am markt einzukaufen
um seinen lieferverpflichtungen
nachzukommen
vng ist deutschlands drittgrößter
gasimporteur deckt als solcher etwa 20
prozent des deutschen gasbedarfs und
beschäftigt 1500 mitarbeiter der
versorger gehört zum energiekonzern enbw
die karlsruher halten 74 prozent am
ostdeutschen unternehmen die restlichen
anteile sind in kommunalen besitz die
nun beantragte staatliche unterstützung
steht trotz der schieflage in der kritik
ist sie überhaupt notwendig denn während
vng in diesem jahr mit einem minus von
rund einer milliarde euro rechnet
erwartet npd voraussichtlich über drei
milliarden gewinn warum also überhaupt
staatliche hilfe der bund wird sich an
der rettung beteiligen gleichzeitig aber
sollte er weiter prüfen inwieweit er
auch die konzernmutter in die pflicht
nehmen kann frank wittmann vielen dank
in kalifornien breitet sich ein großer
waldbrand schnell aus die flammen des
verbrauchers haben sich inzwischen über
7700 hektar fläche ausgedehnt tausende
menschen mussten ihre häuser verlassen
zwei menschen kamen ums leben die
brandursache ist noch unklar seit tagen
herrschen in den us-bundesstaaten
kalifornien nevada und arizona
temperaturen von bis zu 43 grad
das war es von uns weitergehen wie schon
angekündigt mit dem zdf politbarometer
und matthias fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer es sind bewegte ja
turbulente zeiten die wir gerade erleben
drücken kann man sich davor kaum schon
gar nicht die politik sie steht unter
zugzwang und besonderer beobachtung
da fällt auf dass die regierung sich
intensiv mit sich selbst beschäftigt
zwar einigkeit demonstriert aber auch
immer wieder in interne ampel konflikte
läuft über ein drittel meint das
verhältnis zwischen spd grünen und fdp
ist er gut aber eine mehrheit attestiert
der ampel ein eher schlechtes verhältnis
untereinander
ein verfrühtes ende dieser
bundesregierung erwarten die meisten
trotzdem nicht eine deutliche mehrheit
geht davon aus dass sie bis zur nächsten
planmäßigen bundestagswahl halten wird
die bundesregierung unter druck die
angespannte stimmung hinterlässt spuren
wenn am nächsten sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre käme die spd unverändert auf 19
prozent die union mit gewinnen deutlich
davor 28 prozent die grünen verlieren
kräftig jetzt 23 fdp mit leichten
verlusten sechs afd 13 linke 5 prozent
beide +1
schauen wir auf unsere top ten die
bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
politikerinnen und politikern die sind
von den befragten neu bestimmt worden
und erstmals zählt mit alice weide eine
vertreterin der afb dazu bei der
bewertung nach sympathie und leistung
auf der skala von +5 bis -5
ist weiter schlusslicht mit einem sehr
schlechten wert minus 2,6 vorletzte
sahra wagenknecht leicht verloren minus
0,7 es folgt friedrich merz mit
zugewinnen christian lindner auch besser
als zuletzt beide minus 0,1 auch markus
söder gewinnt dazu jetzt 0,0 karl
lauterbach 0,0 olaf scholz jetzt 0,5 cem
özdemir 0,7 alle drei mit klaren
verlusten
annalena baerbock verliert noch
deutlicher 0,8 robert habeck weiter auf
dem ersten platz allerdings mit den
größten verlusten
0,9
die grünen also im sinkflug
krisenstimmung nicht nur mit blick auf
einen möglichen heißen herbst und einen
kalten winter sondern auch in den
umfragewerten
angesichts steigender preise hat die
regierung ein weiteres entlastungspaket
vorgestellt der katalog an maßnahmen
liest sich umfangreich unter anderem
sollen rentner und studierende
einmalzahlungen erhalten
dass die bundesregierung zu viel für die
entlastung der bürger tut meinen gerade
mal fünf prozent mehr als ein drittel
findet das entlastungspaket gerade
richtig fast die hälfte meint die
regierung tut immer noch zu wenig geht
es um bürger mit geringem einkommen
sagen 68 prozent die entlastungen
müssten größer sein
vor allem die energiepreise explodieren
eine direkte folge des ukraine kriegs
dennoch meint eine deutliche mehrheit
dass deutschland die ukraine weiter
unterstützen sollte auch wenn das für
uns hohe energiepreise bedeutet zwölf
prozent machen sich wegen der
energiekrise sehr große
35% große sorgen bei 39 prozent ist die
sorge nicht so groß und 13 prozent
machen sich da keine sorgen
nachdem russland den gashahn weitgehend
und wohl auf dauer zugedreht hat braucht
es übergangs und notlösungen für den
winter so plant etwa wirtschaftsminister
habeck zwei atomkraftwerke sollen bis
april als reserve einsatzbereit bleiben
zur energiesicherung
12 prozent meinen die atomkraftwerke
sollen planmäßig zum jahreswechsel vom
netz und ein drittel ist für
atomkraftwerke als reserve mehr als die
hälfte ist dafür die letzten akw länger
laufen zu lassen
die energiekrise kann leicht vergessen
machen dass dann noch ein beunruhigendes
thema im herbst an die tür klopfen
könnte corona ist auch noch da
aktuell halten aber die meisten ihre
gesundheit durch das virus nicht für
gefährdet der bundestag hat gestern das
neue
infektionsschutzgesetz beschlossen damit
sind auch wieder schärfere vorgaben zu
masken und tests möglich bei einer neuen
corona welle im herbst ist die mehrheit
für erneut strengere schutzmaßnahmen
58 prozent das sind 7 punkte weniger als
noch im august der widerstand gegen
schärfere massnahmen wächst 40 prozent
sind jetzt dagegen
insgesamt sehen wir eher unsicheren
zeiten entgegen
zwischen krieg und energiekrise
explodierenden preisen und corona gefahr
die aussichten für die nächsten monate
könnten gerne etwas freundlicher sein
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in unserer zdf heute app und oft zdf
heute.de
wie die repräsentativen umfragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer
gibt es dann am 30 september dann auch
zur bevorstehenden landtagswahl in
niedersachsen
hier folgt jetzt das wetter und dann die
heute schon einen schönen abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
das wochenende wird nur mäßig warm
unbeständig und windig denn tief peggy
zieht genau über uns hinweg zum beginn
der neuen woche schaufelt dann der ex
hurrikan danielle aber noch mal warme
luft zu uns aber zunächst zum relativ
kühlen wochenende mit nur 14 bis 8 grad
morgen früh dazu ziehen schauer und
gewitter nach nordosten ab in der
zweiten nachthälfte kommt im süd westen
neuer regen auf und er breitet sich
morgen vormittag dann im westen und im
süden weiter aus im norden und im osten
ist es oft freundlich nachmittag sind
dann aber auch hier viele kurze schauer
und gewitter unterwegs im westen und der
mitte haben wir noch diesen gewittrigen
regen mit dem auflebenden wind und hier
haben wir auch nur temperaturen zwischen
15 und 20 grad im osten immerhin bis 21
grad am sonntag hängen die reste der
gewitterwolken noch im südosten von
westen wird das wetter aber schon wieder
ruhiger und bis dienstag schaffen ist
die temperaturen im südwesten auf 28
grad ja und jetzt zum schluss noch zu
einer wettererscheinung gestern in
london im buckingham-palast erschien
persönlich ein doppelter regenbogen und
auch bei uns waren die in dieser woche
ja häufig zu sehen für regenbogen
braucht man ja gleichzeitig sonne und
regen wird das sonnenlicht in den
regentropfen gebrochen und einmal
reflektiert dann entsteht der haupt
regenbogen bei zwei reflektionen
entsteht der neben regenbogen
theoretisch existieren aber bis zu 20
regenbögen an unterschiedlichen
positionen am himmel der dritte zum
beispiel erscheint gegenüber der ersten
beiden sie werden allerdings immer licht
schwächer und sind in der natur mit dem
auge nicht mehr zu erkennen ihnen
erstmal eine gute nacht